бажаним гостем ви себе тут не відчуваєте
судячи з того як з тобою
розмовляють багато мігрантів у Німеччині
почуваються Як яйран початок життя на
Новій батьківщині ускладнює скажена
бюрократія довге очікування на прийом у
чиновників складні курси німецької мови
і все ж багато хто як Каталіна з
Колумбії наважується зробити цей крок у
невідомість хочу набути досвіду життя за
межами своєї країни далеко від сім'ї щоб
зрозуміти чи зможу з цим поратись
з якими викликами стикаються мігранти і
як реагують німецькі установи на
критику дуже
добре Каталіна фахардо хоче поїхати до
Німеччини як педагогиня для отримання
робочої візи колумбійці Необхідно
володіти німецькою на рівні Б2 тобто
достатньому для спілкування та читання
але легкою німецьку мову не
назвеш
вивчати німецьку мову як іноземну
складно бо в ній багато дуже чітко
визначених структур і ці граматичні
правила швидко
забуваються інтенсивний мовний курс у
богаті починається з нуля і триває 7
місяців його організувало німецьке
Агентство з працевлаштування студенти
зобов'язуються займатися по кілька годин
на день відмовляючись на цей час від
іншої оплачуваної роботи натомість Вони
отримують стипендію у розмірі близько
300 євро Каталіна вивчала в Колумбії
педагогіку та психологію тепер вона може
працювати у Німеччині вихователькою в
дитячому садку втім Каталіна не хоче
зупинятися на
досягнутому у мене склалося враження що
Німеччина є досить багато національною
країною це гарне місце для того щоб
обмінюватися ідеями і Займатися тим що
важливо для мене це хороший спосіб
розвиватися в моїй
професії через кілька тижнів у каталіни
іспит на рівень Б2 якщо вона його не
пройде одразу курс буде подовжено але
розмір стипендії зменшиться скласти
іспит з першого разу вдається далеко не
всім звісно Ми сподіваємося що Всі
здадуть успішно Але зрозуміло здатид
дуже
складно каталіні дозволять поїхати до
Німеччини лише після того як вона
успішно здасть мовний тест інакше візу
вона не отримає досить стресова ситуація
для молодої
жінки яйран монтехос Куби живе в
Німеччині вже близько ми років наразі в
Берліні і все ще чекає на дозвіл на
постійне
проживання ось саме такий у мене вирс
обличчя щороку коли я маю продовжувати
свою візу коли я у відомстві у справах
іноземців не знаю що на мене там чекаю
цього разу чи отримую я черговий дозвіл
на рік чи на півроку чи взагалі жодного
це те що я хотів тут
висловити яйран приїхав до Німеччини
оскільки на кубі закохався у стюардесу
вони одружилися та вирішили разом жити в
Німеччині але попри шлюб із німкиною
отримати візу виявилося непросто
щоб приїхати до Німеччини ми мали
довести я і моя тодішня дружина що ми
були разом як довго надати
фотографії ми надрукували такі
фотографії якщо немає переконливих
доказів то вас можуть взагалі не
впустити сюди навіть якщо Ви одружені у
Німеччині кохання в якийсь момент минуло
залишатися разом лише заради документів
вони не захотіли і вже протягом трьх
років яйран змушений продовжувати свій
дозвіл на проживання щороку для цього
потрібно постійно приходити до відомства
у справах
іноземців А це жахливо тому що багато
часу дуже багато часу займає навіть щоб
просто записатися на прийом у цьому
відомстві під час пандемії коронавірусу
одного разу йому довелося чекати так
довго що термін дії його дозволу на той
час офіційно закінчився через це він
навіть Втратив роботу
іноді це означає залишатися місяць чи
два без роботи це надто довго ви собі
напевно навіть уявити таке не можете я
навіть втратив квартиру бо якщо ти не
працюєш то не можеш собі її
дозволити яйран втомився від цієї
ситуації щоразу походи до відомства у
справах іноземців
непередбачувані стоїш нескінченно у
черзі
то співробітників немає на місці то
немає потрібних
документів у Німеччині все працює
інакше наразі є Іран намагається
записатися на прийом в управлінні у
справах іноземців у Берліні де він
нарешті мав би отримати дозвіл на
постійне проживання після сьми років
перебування у Німеччині Але чи вдасться
йому це І ось Приблизно через місяць
яйран готується до зустрічі з
чиновниками звісно я хвилююся але
оскільки я отримав підтвердження з
відомства у справах іноземців все в
принципі має бути гаразд і не повинно
зайняти багато
часу до відомства у справах іноземців
Лише кілька хвилин їзди після прибуття
яйран має спершу зареєструватися на
пропускному пункті перед будинком
відомства В Берліні багато
співробітників охорони і людей які чекаю
на
прим розмова зі співробітницею На вході
триває підозріло
довго я мушу О 12:45 знову сюди прийти
оскільки мені перепризначили час
прийому Вони сказали
Чому вони сказали що просто змінили час
і що мені слід радіти бо я маю тепер
трохи часу
яйрану доводиться чекати ще кілька годин
і сподіватися на те що прийом такий
відбудеться адже йдеться про постійне
проживання в Німеччині дуже багато
мігрантів скаржаться на подібні труднощі
із записом на прийом в німецьких
установах чому це власне так
представники відомства у Берліні не
схотіли говорити на
камеру водночас у такому ж відомстві у
місті ремшайт у землі північний
рейнвестфлія погодилися на зйомку тут
працюють 38 людей за 8 років персонал
установи збільшився більш ніж удвічі
керівник відділу дід мармурах каже що з
2015 року кількість Запитів на прийом
різко
зросла Це була звичайно Велика Хвиля
біженців у 2015 році яку всі пам'ятають
і досі коли до Німеччини приїхали
стільки людей так було і в ремшайді якщо
у
2013-14 роках У нас у ремшайді було
приблизно 17
То тепер їх майже
24000 серйозним тягарем є не тільки
стрімке зростання кількості мігрантів та
біженців а й нестача персоналу відіграє
роль і плинність кадрів у ремшаті штат
співробітників постійно змінюються
оскільки деякі з них не справляються з
навантаженням після стажування мені
спочатку довелося збагнути що містіл
ніколи не буде порожнім досягти цього
практично неможливо рішення які
доводиться приймати пов'язані з великим
стресом і не завжди даються легко діалог
з людьми коли доводиться говорити їм
Вибачте я не можу продовжити ваше
перебування Ми змушені попросити вас
залишити
країну не тільки емоційний стрес
погіршує ситуацію також відставання в
дигіталізації тут у нас усе заповнено
майже під зав'язку але в іншому офісі де
я сиджу шафи іноді настільки забиті що
нам доводиться класти нові папки просто
зверху або збоку
бо тут вони вже не
вміщаються недостатня цифровізація
відчувається у Німеччині й у інших
сферах це проблема на яку вже давно
мають звернути увагу політики вважають у
місцевих органах влади перенесімося
назад у боготу Каталіна з другої спроби
склала мовний тест необхідний для
отримання робочої візи на роботу до ФРН
її запросило Агентство з
працевлаштування таalent Orange і ось
Каталіна з нетерпінням чекає приїзду до
Німеччини хочу набути досвіду життя за
межами своєї країни далеко від сім'ї щоб
зрозуміти чи зможу я з цим впоратися чи
зможу я взагалі так жити і тоді можливо
залишуся перед від'їздом Каталіна
проводить час із старшим братом оскаром
вона молодша з трьох дітей у сім'ї та
перша хто наважився емігрувати старший
брат обіцяє незабаром відвідати
її нехай насолоджується і більше
подорожує ми знову в Німеччині у місті
ганау Каталіна працюватиме в дитячому
садку на кшталт цього у Німеччині не
вистачає майже 100 000 вихователів у
дитячих садках в одному лише ганау
дефіцит персоналу в дедсадках становить
близько 80 осіб за рахунок залучення
кваліфікованих іноземців місто зможе
закрити принаймні частину вакансій і
досі такий досвід був
позитивним ми бачимо що поїхати за
кордон і працювати там - дуже сильний
мотивуючий факт Даніела Ноя з Колумбії
до ганау переїхала вже близько року тому
як їй тут
живеться одна складність - це погода
Оскільки у нас у Колумбії немає пірроку
і зима була дуже складна для нас ну і
мабуть
мова мігранти які приїхали до Німеччини
через Агентство з працевлаштування мають
явні переваги інша ситуація якщо людина
приїхала самостійно як приміром яйран в
очікуванні відкладеної зустрічі він
провів кілька годин і тепер знову йде до
установи Щоб нарешті отримати дозвіл на
постійне проживання я хвилююся і тим не
менше сповнели Надії що цього разу все
вдасться і знову натовп іноземців перед
відомством і знову яйран повинен
проходити повз
[музика]
охоронців цього разу кубинця впускають
всередину за кілька хвилин він
повертається
так вийшло тривало трохи довше за те
вийшло і картка ПМЖ у мене оце ма стара
А це
нова яйран монтехо таки досяг свого
після ми років перебування в Німеччині
та незлічинних зустрічей з
чиновниками Це справжній прогрес мені не
треба більше сюди
приходити Життя
продовжується
наступний можливий крок для яйрана
німецьке громадянство шлях до нього
також швидше за все буде пов'язаний із
численними перепунами та неприємними
сюрпризами